the one of one content was the concept
that we've adhered to now as the team
started to see what was going to happen
for the event and how much we were
putting into it and all the free stuff
we were going to give away and how much
money we were choosing actively to not
make they were like dude no one would do
this they're like this isn't even one of
one they're like this is one of zero it
was like that's it for 18 months I've
been looking for a saying or an ism that
was short and could encapsulate many of
the values skills that can be learned
that I believe are important and that
one of zero concept which I love because
also from a math perspective one of zero
you know one divided by Z is undefined
it's really about being Beyond
definition writing your own path you
know keeping promises in a world that
breaks them delaying expectations giving
first and giving over and over again
until they ask or even if they never ask
and trying to live your life in a way
that you earn your own approval by the
end of it and I think that's what one of
zero is all about